well I think if you're a startup you
know it's really important to get all
the help you can get and if if skills is
our biggest issue which it is then you
know you need to make sure that you have
affordability and you're investing in
the right place if you also then have to
pay a levy on top of that for your top
talent then you know that's not going to
do anything other than be negative for
the business the government would make
the point that the levy is charged as a
thousand pounds but for a small business
like a start-up it comes down to 364
pounds yes it does but it's still a
charge and and I think what I would call
on the government to do is to use that
money wisely and I think there's going
to be something the order of 250 million
pounds raised from the skills levy is
that they use that to fund domestic
skills training because we simply aren't
training our own domestic skills pool
fast enough but in general the
government has issued this levy because
they want to reduce dependence on
migrant labor I mean that surely a good
thing isn't it well I'm not sure I mean
an you know our tech sector has thrived
because of the international ideas
innovation and talent that's come from
overseas you know half of the UK's
unicorns were built by non UK nationals
so should we took should we really close
the door on billion-dollar opportunities
I'm not sure the answer is yes what
about the election is this a disruption
for the tech industry what sort of
messages are you trying to get out
during the campaign during the campaign
i think you know we are really concerned
about the skills gap with we're simply
creating more jobs than we can fill and
so we really need the government to
focus on how we're going to create a
global model for a a modern Britain and
that that really means putting our best
foot forward with with the industrial
and technical you know strategy for for
digital Britain and do you talk
concerned about some of the noises that
have been coming from jeremy corbyn's in
the last 48 hours higher taxes on anyone
over earning more than 70,000 pansy I
mean that will hit an awful lot of
people in the
except to want it yeah i mean the tech
sector is a sector where people do earn
very well and i think it just have to be
a fair tax levy for everybody and yes of
course it does hit us but actually I do
think if the tax system has looked at as
a whole versus in part then that's a
much smarter way to look at it obviously
the election is being called to improve
Theresa May's negotiating position over
brexit what's the tech industry looking
for from those negotiations the tech
industry really needs the government to
address the skills gap and really needs
the government to look at things like
securing the data standards so that we
are at least at the same level as
European standards for data because the
tech industry and data doesn't really
know any boundaries and in order to do
business we really need to get that
right and on top of that we probably
need to be very well aligned on our
security and cyber strategies as well
that's a really interesting point that
you make about cybersecurity you think
brexit puts the UK at risk from more
cyber attacks why no I don't think it
puts us at risk it more the more cyber
attacks but I think we need to have
strong relationships so that we can join
together to partner against the risk of
raised threat externally